die deutsche fußball nationalmannschaft
hat ihr letztes freundschaftsspiel vor
der wm gewonnen
das 2 1 gegen saudi arabien war
allerdings glanzlos bundestrainer
joachim löw sagte nach dem match am
freitag in leverkusen wenn man es auf
den punkt bringen will
eigentlich haben zu viele chancen
ausgelassen und zu viele chancen
zugelassen
vom gegner denke wir haben gut
angefangen erste halbzeit war gut unser
spiel nach vorne war sehr agil ist sehr
beweglich und aufgrund von einigen sehr
gut heraus gespielten chancen in der
zweiten halbzeit kann man nachgelassen
unsere spielweise hermann dann auch viel
mehr räume den gegner gelassen wir
hatten mehr ballverluste haben viel
weniger zum abschluss und von daher
hatte der gegner dann einfach auf zu
viel platz und zu viel raum in diesem
spiel um selber zu torchancen zu kommen
unverständnis äußerte löw zum verhalten
einiger fans die den deutschen
nationalspieler ilkay gündogan bei jedem
ballkontakt ausgepfiffen hatten william
und sein teamkollege mesut özil hatten
sich im mai in london mit dem türkischen
präsidenten recep tayyip erdogan
getroffen
das stieß bei vielen fans auf teils
scharfe kritik ich ganz schwer
nachvollziehen das ist gespalten hat
sich jetzt mehrfach eigentlich auch den
medien gestellt der öffentlichkeit
gestellt hat gesprochen
das was ich gehört habe diese woche in
eppan das ist es nochmals auch in der
öffentlichkeit gesagt hat was er uns
schon gesagt hat meinem verband oder den
trainern oliver auch seinen mitspielern
dass ich absolut mit den werten von
deutschland und mit den werten wie wir
hier leben identifiziert dass er keine
politische botschaft senden wollte und
ich denke wenn ein spieler das dann auch
sagt und das mehrfach sagt dann ist auch
mal irgendwann ist dann einfach auch mal
gut
nun soll alle konzentration auf die wm
gerichtet werden das turnier in russland
beginnt am kommenden donnerstag
deutschland spielt sein erstes match am
17 juni gegen mexiko